so originally before you moved to Cali
where are you originally from Dallas oh
you're from Dallas originally Southwest
I used to uh well I I I had a girl I was
[ __ ] with that was a um
Twin Peaks waitressing planet in Plano
Texas Peaks oh my God I didn't know you
[ __ ] white girls who like cats no
definitely not white really Twin Peaks
lovely uh lovely light-skinned uh young
uh sister in uh Plano Texas about six
years ago
Twin Peaks Plano Texas I don't know man
yeah that's odd that's the only time I
only went to I went to Dallas one time
for Wrestlemania in like 2015. okay we
had a hotel in Plano I went to a strip
club
that was called Onyx maybe I don't know
but yeah it was like a BYOB strip club
which they don't have I think that's
just in Texas I've been a one may have
been a couple bring your own bottles I
had been in one strip club by the time I
was like 27 or something and then I got
a free lap dance because I was so
uncomfortable that the girl thought it
was hilarious yeah to just give me a lap
dance yeah the whole uh the strip club
Dynamic is interesting son it's a
terrible place it's there's no cemetery
on Earth As Dead As a stripper's eyes
and they just sit on your lap and just
just like assume that that's what you
want and then when you say oh no I'm
good they get up and they it's like
they're offended it goes from nice to
attitude so fast like I'm here for
chicken wings yeah oh you know I'm here
because my friend wants to get the link
talk to him I'm just hanging out 100
there's bachelor party 95 of the time so
what are we doing yeah the saddest thing
I remember watching the guys like put
the dollar bills like on the ground or
whatever it wasn't even as sad as at the
end of the song watching them Scurry the
strippers to pick up like eight dollars
I was like yo this is sad though that is
is the most uh demeaning part of the
strip club experience is at the end of
the girls stage she has to bend down and
she has to I would rather if I'm a woman
I think I'd rather you put it in my
[ __ ] g-string ass crack yeah then I
got a Scurry like a mouse especially if
they make it rain like there's a there's
a club in L.A called Sam's that's like
uh the middle stage is just full of like
10 girls yeah and if I make it rain on
one girl every girl on stage has a right
to any of the money that touches the
stage so when people make it rain it's
like throwing [ __ ] pigeon food at the
park
it's [ __ ] crazy it's like it's like
it's like the funnest strip club to go
to if you really want to just be a piece
of [ __ ] and watch chicks hit the floor
and like dive for money you're like let
me get 100 once and cause some [ __ ]
chaos complete degenerate that would be
fun yeah you know it's not bad